would you ever find yourself so tired
that your comedy would shift meaner
what's a Conan that's suffering on
burnout look like when you're thrust
well everyone here in the room just
there's something I know maybe I should
ask you guys
that's like you're sitting with Stalin
and his Pilot Bureau and you're saying
um hey Stalin it's over a time when you
get a little grumpy and what's that look
like and everyone else
bukarin crew Chef I'm always happy
always
great he's a good guy
fun at party never kill my wife yeah
well one time but not second wife yet
maybe we'll certainly you can speak to
this excuse me I'm a master of passive
aggression and so yeah